[Music]
county commission chairwoman marilyn
kirkpatrick is stepping down today the
board voted on a new leader while paying
tribute to the outgoing one christian
casadas joining us now live in studio
this was a real moment for commissioner
kirkpatrick who has had a very long
career on this board kristin that's
right denise well since 2015 marilyn
kirkpatrick has been serving on the
clark county board of commissioners but
it wasn't until 2019 that she was
appointed chair today she held back
tears as her board members thanked her
for her leadership
surrounded by flowers marilyn
kirkpatrick steps down as chair of the
clark county commissioners a title she's
held since 2019 during the board's
monthly meeting a video highlighting
kirkpatrick's work was shown before each
commissioner personally thanked her
kirkpatrick has served on numerous
boards and commissions promising her
more than 300 thousand constituents to
make county government work for citizens
and improve the communities that we call
home i wanted people to know that
counties do matter
and we do a lot of stuff for a lot of
people
um
so
if none of this could have been done
though without
our
our team our employees because everybody
throughout the last three years have
stepped up so i'm super excited
to take vacation commissioner
kirkpatrick added that a good leader
always steps down to let others flourish
she said she is excited for her next
chapter and continues to work together
to improve our community kirkpatrick
will remain as a board member
the board also voted on commissioner jim
gibson to take over the leadership role
and commissioner justin jones as the
vice chair they officially start on
january 4th christian gossett is live
local now